Les rivages tranquilles des océans
servent de cadre à un monde marin,
dont le passé fut souvent
violent et effrayant.
De vrais monstres ont jadis hanté ces
profondeurs, puis ils ont disparu.
Mais en laissant derrière eux des preuves
étonnantes de leur existence.
Aujourd'hui, les paléontologues
découvrent beaucoup de pistes,
qui les conduisent à ces monstres
qui peuplaient les mers.
Dans les océans, la sécurité
a toujours été très éphémère.
La mort frappe sans prévenir
et la pitié n'existe pas.
L'attaque se déclenche
toujours brusquement.
Des dents aiguisées comme des rasoirs
écharpent la chair et broient les os.
Des prédateurs que nous connaissons
comme le requin font pâle figure,
comparé à ces créatures qui semaient
la terreur dans les mers.
Imaginez une créature plus grosse
et plus rapide qu'un épaulard,
et plus puissante qu'un grand requin blanc.
Ou un animal avec un cou si long qu'il pouvait
attraper un oiseau dans le ciel.
Une bête étrange qui a probablement inspiré
la légende du monstre du Loch Ness.
À moins de 100 kilomètres de Laramie,
dans le Wyoming,
à un endroit baptisé Medicine Bow,
Robert Bakker fouille la poussière
à la recherche de traces d'ichtyosaures.
Une dent...
J'ai mené une vie pure,
je mérite une dent.
Il y a 245000000 d'années, les dinosaures ont
régné sur la Terre pendant 150 millions d'années.
À la même époque, des reptiles devenus
des prédateurs féroces régnaient dans les eaux.
Bizarrement, leurs ancêtres
vivaient sur la terre ferme,
et attrapaient leurs proies en galopant
sur leur 4 pattes.
Mais pour pouvoir survivre, ils furent
obligés de s'adapter à la vie aquatique.
Ces animaux sont passés de la terre à la mer
pour une raison toute simple,
Le stress,
les pressions exercées par la famille.
Quand on est nés reptiles ou lions,
on grandit entouré de frères,
de tantes et d'oncles qui tous cherchent
des proies, des tanières et des territoires.
Le résultat est qu'il arrive
un moment où on vous expulse.
Alors, si on vit sur terre, une façon
d'aller voir ailleurs est de se jeter à l'eau.
Je ne vois pas d'autres bonnes raisons
et au début de l'âge des reptiles,
c'est devenu tout à fait commun.
Au début de l'ère Mésozoïque,
les masses terrestres s'étaient déjà
réunies en un seul supercontinent,
Pangée, entouré d'un seul océan, Téthys,
aux eaux riches en substances nutritives.
C'est au cours de l'ère Mésozoïque
qui débuta il y a 245000000 d'années,
que les reptiles s'emparèrent
de la terre, de la mer et des airs.
Ces eaux représentaient l'idéal pour le développement
d'une des créatures marines les plus minuscules,
Le plancton.
Dans Thétys, le plancton croissait
et multipliait d'une façon incroyable.
L'abondance du plancton,
offrait aux poissons de l'ère mésozoïque,
une nourriture quasi inépuisable.
Il devint innombrable.
Le décor était planté pour l'apparition
de nouveaux prédateurs,
et les reptiles s'intéressèrent rapidement
à tout ce monde grouillant dans l'eau.
Leurs puissantes mâchoires ne tardèrent pas
à faire la loi dans l'océan.
Il y a 220000000 d'années,
cette magnifique chaîne de montagnes de la
Colombie-Britannique était au fond de la mer.
Kris McGowan, du Musée royal de l'Ontario,
vient ici tous les printemps depuis 1987.
Il est à la recherche du plus ancien
de tous les monstres marins.
Tandis que la plupart des paléontologues
taillent la roche avec précaution,
McGowan et son équipe utilisent
des méthodes plus radicales.
Le sol est particulièrement dur.
On doit enlever le rocher
couche par couche.
Et tout en faisant ce travail pénible,
toute l'équipe ouvre l'oeil.
Un morceau de roche un peu étrange
pourrait offrir de l'intérêt.
Par exemple, un indice concernant
ces créatures fantastiques,
qui ont pris possession des mers.
À première vue, ces fragments
ne ressemblent pas à grand chose.
Ce sont pourtant les os fossilisés d'un ancien
reptile ressemblant à un dauphin, l'ichtyosaure.
Tout le monde a entendu parler des dinosaures,
mais peu de gens connaissent les ichtyosaures.
Et c'était pourtant des animaux plus
intéressants que les dinosaures.
Les uns régnaient sur la terre,
les autres dans l'eau.
Le premier fossile d'un reptile marin fut
découvert en Angleterre en 1811,
c'est à dire une dizaine d'années avant
qu'on fasse la connaissance du premier dinosaure.
Un observateur pensa que ce n'était
peut-être pas tout à fait un poisson,
et l'animal fut baptisé ichtyosaure,
c'est à dire lézard poisson.
Les ichtyosaures étaient des nageurs rapides
qui dépassaient 70 kilomètres heure.
Une puissante nageoire caudale
fournissait l'impulsion principale,
et une nageoire dorsale supprimait le roulis.
Comme tous les reptiles,
ils avaient besoin d'air pour respirer,
et avaient des narines haut placées
sur leur grand museau.
Leurs longues mâchoires, bien pourvues de dents
en faisaient des prédateurs redoutables.
Certains avaient la taille d'un saumon,
d'autres étaient aussi gros qu'une baleine.
Leur caractéristique principale était leurs
yeux énormes, ressemblant à de petits melons,
et qui leur permettaient d'y voir
dans les eaux sombres pour chasser.
Les ichtyosaures furent les premiers à exploiter
l'abondante réserve de nourriture,
que recelait l'océan.
Au début, il n'y avait personne
pour leur faire concurrence.
Ils se nourrissaient de poissons, de
crustacés et d'ammonites géantes,
un coquillage d'un mètre de diamètre.
Mais il n'est pas exclu que leur appétit vorace
les ai conduit à se dévorer les uns les autres.
Certains ont longtemps cherché
des traces de cannibalisme.
On a retrouvé des spécimens fossiles
où le squelette d'un petit ichtyosaure,
se trouve encore à l'intérieur
du corps de l'adulte.
En sortant même un peu, sans doute par
la voie de passage servant à la naissance.
Il y a des cas de naissance post-mortem.
L'animal mort se décompose
et la pression des gaz dans l'abdomen,
pousse le fœtus vers l'extérieur.
Les reptiles pondent normalement des œufs.
Le fait que les ichtyosaures donnent
naissance à leur petit en mer,
prouve à quel point ils avaient su
s'adapter à l'élément marin.
Mais ils avaient toujours
besoin d'air pour respirer.
La forme de l'animal se modifiait
à chaque génération nouvelle.
Au cours de 100 millions d'années, il perdirent
leur silhouette reptilienne un peu massive.
Ils finirent par ressembler à l'actuel dauphin,
dont la tête se prolonge
d'une espèce de bec garnie de dents.
Ils étaient fait pour la vitesse.
La raison du changement était la concurrence.
D'autres reptiles abandonnant
la lutte avec les dinosaures,
venaient trouver refuge dans l'océan.
Ils allaient y introduire de nouvelles méthodes
pour chasser et pour tuer.
La bataille pour la conquête des mers
ne faisait que commencer.
Pendant des siècles, les marins sont rentrés
au port avec des histoires fantastiques,
de monstres marins.
Et Hollywood a essayé de gagner de l'argent
avec les mêmes histoires à dormir debout.
La taille des dinosaures !
Le plus terrifiant de tous les temps.
À la base de tous ces contes fantastiques,
il y a quand même une part de vérité.
La réalité dépasse souvent
la fiction quand on parle,
de la taille et de la férocité
des monstres marins de la préhistoire.
Depuis des siècles, les carrières
de Holzmaden en Allemagne,
ont fourni de la pierre
pour construire routes et maisons,
mais elles renfermaient aussi des trésors,
les fossiles de plus de 3000 ichtyosaures.
Il y a 160000000 d'années, une large mer intérieure
couvrait la plus grande partie de l'Europe.
Cette carrière se trouvait
alors au fond d'un lagon,
semblable à celui qui existe
en Colombie-Britannique.
Quand un animal marin mourait,
le gaz produit par la décomposition,
faisait remonter son corps à la surface.
La carcasse était alors rejetée
sur le rivage où elle se désintègrait,
si elle n'était pas dévorée.
Mais de temps en temps,
un cadavre coulé au fond de la mer,
et un long processus de fossilisation se mettait
en route, pétrifie tant les os dans le calcaire.
C'est ce qui nous permet d'admirer
aujourd'hui les ardoises de Poséidon.
Au cours des années, les trouvailles
ont été nombreuses et spectaculaires.
C'est le musée de Stuttgart qui expose
les plus beaux spécimens.
On y trouve même un fossile de plésiosaure.
Bob Bakker pense que c'était l'une des espèces
les plus importantes de l'ère Mésozoïque.
C'est à cause du plésiosaure que cette ère
a été baptisée l'âge des reptiles.
Ces animaux marins géants,
découverts vers 1790,
nous ont aidé à comprendre que les océans
étaient dominés par ses cousins du lézard.
On trouve surtout des plésiosaures ainsi
que d'autres monstres reptiliens géants,
dans des endroits où il y avait
ce qu'on appelle des vagues platoniques.
Et il s'agissait d'eau peu profonde et
chaude, comme celle qui couvrait,
des milliers de kilomètres carrés
au milieu de l'Amérique du Nord,
au milieu de l'Amérique du Sud
et au milieu de l'Australie.
Aujourd'hui, on visualise les continents
comme des étendues de terre,
mais ce n'était pas vrai dans le passé,
ils abritaient d'immenses régions
où la vie était surtout aquatique.
Les plésiosaures commencèrent à établir leur
règne sur les océans il y a 160000000 d'années.
Au fur et à mesure que les reptiles
effectuaient leur retour à la mer.
Pesant cinq tonnes comme un bel éléphant,
les plésiosaures possédaient un corps massif
surmonté d'une petite tête.
À l'inverse des ichtyosaures,
ils avaient gardé leurs pattes de derrière,
c'était peut-être un avantage
dans les eaux peu profondes.
Moi, j'ai baptisé les plésiosaures :
doubles pingouins.
Allez visiter un zoo ou un aquarium
et regarder les pingouins nager.
Ils possèdent une paire de nageoires,
une seule paire.
Une nageoire de chaque côté
et ils sont rapides et très agiles.
Les plésiosaures avaient une paire
de nageoires devant et une autre à l'arrière.
Ce sont les seuls animaux qui, en évoluant,
ont gardé la configuration des épaules
et des hanches, y ajoutant des nageoires.
Ça leur permettait d'atteindre
une grande vitesse et d'être très mobiles.
Leurs yeux jouaient un grand rôle
dans la poursuite de leurs proies.
Certains, comme kronosaurus, mesurait
17 mètres, dont 4 pour la tête.
Il était capable d'avaler un animal
de la taille d'un épaulard tout entier.
On a dénombré une vingtaine
d'espèces de plésiosaures.
Elasmosaurus avait un cou long et flexible
d'environ huit mètres, comportant 76 vertèbres.
Un autre groupe, les pliosaures,
avaient au contraire des cous épais et courts.
Voici un pliosaure,
animal au cou puissant et court.
C'était un prédateur féroce.
Son corps était trapu et une petite queue
lui servait de gouvernail.
Il avait deux paires de nageoires
qui ressemblaient à celles des pingouins.
Vu de côté, son énorme tête ressemblait
un peu à celle d'un crocodile.
Ses grands yeux lui donnaient
un degré de vision très important.
La forme de son corps et ses 4 nageoires pagaies
permettaient au pliosaure de se mouvoir dans l'eau,
à une vitesse dépassant 50 km/h.
Il y a 130000000 d'années,
au début du Crétacé,
les pliosaures devinrent gigantesques.
Kronosaurus était le plus grand de tous.
Ce spécimen effrayant trouvé en Australie
mesurait 17 mètres de long, dont 4 pour la tête.
Ses mâchoires lui auraient permis
d'avaler une vache.
Tandis que les pliosaures aux gueules
impressionnantes continuaient à grossir,
les plésiosaures s'allongeaient.
Elasmosaurus atteignit une vingtaine de mètres.
Son cou de dix mètres était
devenu une arme redoutable.
Il se détendait comme un serpent
et malheur au poisson sans défense.
À la différence des ichtyosaures qui avaient
perdu la faculté de sortir de l'eau,
il est possible que les plésiosaures aient passé
une partie de leur temps sur la terre ferme.
L'étude de leur squelettes suggère
qu'ils étaient amphibies.
Leur anatomie était semblable à celle
des tortues de mer que nous connaissons.
Ils avaient un corps large et trapu et la région
du ventre était protégée par une carapace.
Leurs pattes arrière puissantes leur permettaient
peut-être de se hisser sur Terre pour y pondre.
Cette possibilité de sortir de l'eau
était peut être leur seule défense,
contre un autre monstre
encore plus dangereux qu'eux,
qui hantait l'océan
il y a 130000000 d'années.
Ce crâne appartient au Mosasaurus Maximus.
Les Mosasaures étaient de taille
à lutter contre les pliosaures.
Si jamais un dragon a existé, c'était lui.
Il mesurait une quinzaine de mètres.
Plusieurs millions d'années d'adaptation
lui avaient donné une configuration effrayante.
Il ne s'agissait plus de la survie du plus résistant,
mais de celle du plus dangereux.
L'évolution avait fabriqué une machine à tuer.
Bill Gallagher,
du Musée d'État du New Jersey,
a toujours été impressionné
par ce titan des mers.
C'était le roi des océans
à la fin du Crétacé,
le plus gros et le plus féroce
animal du monde marin.
Il représentait sans aucun doute
le Tyrannosaurus rex de la mer.
On a trouvé les mâchoires de deux Mosasaures
qui étaient encore pourvues de longues dents,
particulièrement tranchantes.
Comme si ce n'était pas suffisant,
ses mâchoires comportaient des doubles charnières,
Qui leur permettaient de s'ouvrir
encore plus grand.
Ils pouvaient avaler leur proie tout entière.
Des muscles puissants refermaient alors leur gueule,
scellant le sort de leurs victimes.
Mais ce n'est pas tout,
L'apophyse d'un os à l'arrière du palais,
portait une deuxième série de dents,
dont l'efficacité s'ajoutait
à celle des mâchoires.
On peut dire qu'il était
la l'hyène de son époque.
Guidés dans la mer comme une anguille
par sa queue longue et flexible,
il battait l'eau de ses larges membres
en forme de pagaie.
Le Mosasaure mangeait
tout ce qui lui faisait envie.
Il avalait des plésiosaures,
des ichtyosaures, des requins,
et tout ce qui avait le malheur
de passer à sa portée.
Leurs nageoires et leur queue
portent souvent des cicatrices,
résultant des attaques de leurs cousins.
Les mosasaures évoluèrent
en plusieurs variétés de tailles différentes.
Ça allait de l'agile Platecarpus
d'environ cinq mètres,
à l'effrayant Mosasaurus Maximus
qui en atteignait presque quinze.
Rester au fond n'offrait aucune protection
aux futures victimes.
Le Mosasaure pouvait plonger
à plus de 30 mètres.
Il s'était si bien adapté et faisait
preuve d'une telle efficacité,
que sa disparition à la fin du Crétacé
intrigue les scientifiques.
Qu'est ce qui a bien pu anéantir
une telle machine à tuer ?
Certains croient qu'un changement de climat
a détruit la chaîne alimentaire,
mais Bob Bakker n'est pas de cet avis.
La chose la plus fascinante
et la plus intrigante aussi,
au sujet de ces monstres marins,
c'est leur lien avec les prédateurs terrestres.
On a les plésiosaures dans l'océan
et les dinosaures sur terre.
Des animaux comme
Tyrannosaurus rex et ses ancêtres.
Ils ne se sont jamais rencontrés. Ils vivent
à des milliers de kilomètres les uns des autres,
et ils sont comme les deux mains
dans l'histoire de l'évolution.
Quand l'évolution a fait disparaître
Tyrannosaurus rex,
Elle n'a épargné aucun de ses cousins.
Les plésiosaures se sont également éteints.
On a de grands prédateurs sur terre
et de grands prédateurs dans la mer.
Il est difficile d'imaginer qu'une seule
modification de l'environnement,
ait pu anéantir en même temps le prédateur marin,
et celui qui vit à 1500 mètres d'altitude
dans la montagne.
Il ne peut s'agir ni d'un changement de
climat, ni de celui du régime des pluies.
D'autres parlent de chute de météorite
pendant le règne des reptiles.
Mais il y a forcément eu autre chose.
Aussi étrange que cela paraisse,
c'est peut-être l'habitant
le plus microscopique des mers,
qui a tué ces monstres.
Il y a environ 75 millions d'années,
une catastrophe mystérieuse a ébranlé l'écosystème.
Avec la dérive des continents,
les courants marins ont changé.
Le plancton en a souffert
et a commencé à disparaître.
Les poissons et les pieuvres qui manquaient
de nourriture n'ont cessé de diminuer,
et à l'autre bout de la chaîne alimentaire,
les plésiosaures et les mosasaures,
ont commencé à s'éteindre.
Ces énormes reptiles marins seraient
donc tous morts de faim,
et leur disparition laissait la place
à des créatures beaucoup plus petites,
qui repeuplèrent les océans.
Mais l'endroit n'en devint pas
plus sûr pour autant.
Le terrain de chasse était prêt à recevoir
un nouveau tueur, plus gros et plus dangereux,
qu'aucun de ceux qui l'avaient précédé.
Dans le film Les Dents de la mer,
un gigantesque requin blanc sème la terreur dans
une station balnéaire de la Nouvelle Angleterre.
Avec ses sept mètres, ce requin a réussi
à terroriser des millions de spectateurs.
Mais il y a 25000000 d'années,
ses cousins parcouraient les mers.
Le requin du film aurait eu l'air d'un nain à
côté du représentant d'une espèce disparue,
baptisé Megalodon.
Mais il y a un air de famille.
On a trouvé des restes de ces monstres
dans le monde entier.
Le docteur Michael Gottfried,
du musée océanographique,
Cherche des fossiles de requins
sur les rives de Chesapeake Bay.
Le mégalodon ou le requin aux méga dents,
comme on le surnomme aussi,
atteignait certainement quinze mètres.
On fait cette estimation en comparant ses dents
à celles du requin blanc qui vit aujourd'hui.
Son poids dépassait sans doute 50 tonnes,
cela représente en gros la taille d'un autobus
et le poids de sept ou huit dinosaures.
Il représente un résumé de l'évolution
du requin prédateur,
le plus grand requin et le plus féroce
qui ait jamais vécu.
Ce que vous voyez là n'est qu'une
reproduction au un huitième.
Une seule dent de ce requin géant mesure
15cm de haut et 12,5cm de diamètre.
Non seulement les dents
sont incroyablement aiguisées,
mais elles sont aussi en dents de scie,
comme un couteau à steak.
Il pouvait donc trancher facilement la chair,
mais aussi scier les os.
Nous avons déjà trouvé des morceaux cassés
de ses dents dans des os de baleine,
ce qui nous prouve qu'il pouvait déchirer la peau,
trancher tout le muscle et arriver jusqu'à l'os.
Les mâchoires de ce requin s'écartaient
de presque deux mètres.
C'était plus que suffisant pour avaler
un dauphin ou un homme d'une seule bouchée.
Comment ces monstres sont devenus
aussi gros demeure un mystère.
La réponse est peut-être qu'ils se nourrissaient
de dauphins et de baleines.
Malheureusement, beaucoup de questions
restent sans réponse.
Les requins sont surtout constitués
de cartilage qui ne se fossilise pas.
On ne peut se baser que sur
des dents et des vertèbres,
et il est douteux que l'on puisse
un jour trouver autre chose.
Les fossiles disponibles aujourd'hui ne nous
apprennent rien sur le sort de ces requins géants.
Ils sont peut-être devenus beaucoup trop gros,
et ont été vaincus par des requins
plus petits et plus agiles.
Ou il est possible que les gros animaux
qu'ils chassaient se soient retirés,
dans des eaux plus froides, hors de leur portée.
Quelle qu'en soit la cause,
les paléontologues estiment que leur extinction
remonte à environ 2 millions d'années.
Les monstres de l'ère Mésozoïque qui peuplent
nos cauchemars et alimentent notre imagination,
ont disparu à jamais.
L'ichyosaure semblable au dauphin,
le plésiosaures au long cou,
et l'horrible kronosaurus se sont
transformés en poussière.
Seul leur fossile extrait du sol
témoigne de leur règne sur les océans.
Disparus aussi, les gigantesques
requins menaçants qui ont suivi.
Mais leurs descendants
sont toujours la terreur des mers.
La roche garde les traces des changements
subtils et perpétuels de notre planète,
au cours de millions d'années.
Ainsi que des raffinements apportés
aux créatures qui la peuplent.